مين الدوحه ينضم لنا المدرب الوطني
السيد بندر اهلا بك معانا منورنا في صباح
العربيه شكرا على تواجدك معانا يعني صقور
الاخضر اوقفه سلسله لا هزيمه لراقصي
التانجو وحصاده ثلاث نقاط ثمينه من اول
مباراه حديثنا اكثر عن هذا الفوز واهميه
صباح الخير
لجميع المشاهدين
معكم في قناه العربيه لكره العرب
بدايه اول شهيه خلينا نشكر خالد معروفين
وولي عهد عليه اهتمام الكبير من
سموه
المال الذي يصرف لهذه الدوله سواء من
اشياء اجتماعيه او حتى في الرياضيات ولكن
لو تكلمنا عن مباراه الامس كان مباراه
قلبت كل التوقعات ااا بالامس اا اثبت
الصقور والخضر وعلى
المستوى اللي قدموه خلال التسعين دقيقه
امام منتخب الثالث في العالم ومنتخب مرشح
لكاس العالم كره القدم دائما تكون فيها
المفاجاه ولكن المفاجاه تاتي احيانا من
مستوى يبهر المتابعين على العمل
اللي عمل ما قبل بدايه كاس العالم التحضير
الجيد بالنسبه للمنتخب السعودي اللي حضوره
وتركيزه ذهني كان هو الواضح
للرياضيات
لو انه نشاهد جميع اللاعبين اللي لعبوا في
المباراه الامس
الى 85 كلهم من شاركوا في كاس العالم اللي
كانت في روسيا فلذلك نجد ان الخبره
متواجده الاحتكاك
متواجد
العامل التحضيري بالنسبه للاعب كان جيد
امام همم
الممالك يمتلك لاعب من افضل اللاعبين في
العالم ولذلك الهيبه في اول مباراه لم تكن
سهله بالنسبه للمنتخب السعودي المجموعه
لازم تكون فيها نوع من النفسيه على
اللاعبين ولكن
نبارك لكم مجددا ونبارك لانفسنا هذا الفوز
المستحق اليوم وحضرتك مدرب وطني ومدرب
سابق للمنتخب الى اي حد ثقه المنتخب
السعودي
تعززت امس بالقوه والاراده يعني كنا نراه
مهاجما اكثر مما نراه مدافعا يعني هذا
يعطي اشارات بانه لا يخشى خصمه نتحدث عن
خاصه مثل الارجنتين
شوفي
انا تحدثت قلنا بدايه بدايه المباريات
دايما تكون لها نوع من الرحمه ولكن كونك
انت تنتهي بالشوط الاول وبضرب الجزائر
بهدف واحد هذا يعطينا نابع انه المنتخب
السعودي ما كان هناك اي ضغوط ايضا عليه
حتى يكون في عمليه اللازمه في اداء
اللاعبين بل الشوط الثاني يتغير كليا اا
اصبح المنتخب السعودي في في حاله هجوميه
سجل هدف تعادل المبكر وترجع امام المنتخب
قوي وتفوز الاثنين وعد هذا مو سهل فلذلك
همم لاعبين المنتخب السعودي زي ما بتحدث
لاعبين يمتلكون كل الامارات اللي همم احنا
دائما نستمتع بها من خلال الدوري او في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فاذا اردت ان
همم
تجعل عندك المنتخب قوي الى لابد يكون عندك
دوري قوي وهذا ما لحضرات من خلال الدوري
السعودي القوي المميز اللي يمتلك كل عناصر
القوه لما يحظى به من لاعبين اجانب هو
اللاعب السعودي استفاد من الخبرات اللي
احنا
نتمرث بها من اللاعبين ذات امكانيات عاليه
الان اصبح عندنا لاعبين التميزون في كيفيه
التعامل مع الفرق الكبيره في المنتخب
السعودي بالامس اثبت للجميع نعم طب هذا
الفوز المشرف للمنتخب السعودي في مقابل
الارجنتين هل يبشر لسلسله انتصارات
متتاليه بالمضيق قدما في هذا الموضوع
شوفي الاهم انه انت لما تكسب مباراه في في
اول مباراه في الجوله هي فرحتها
ولكن هي فتره مؤقته
لاستعداد لمباراه
القادمه لا بدي كلها تحضير جيد لا بده
يكون لها اهتمام وتركيز من قبل اللاعبين
وننسى المباراه اللي كانت امام الارجنتين
ولذلك هذه هي كره القدم اذا خاصه في
مباريات اليوم فيها نقاب انك لما تفوز في
مباراه الاولى فكر في المباراه التي
الهدف اللي انت من اجله ان تصل للمبتغارات
هو ايضا نعم يعني في نقطه لم يتم التركيز
عليها في الطرف الاخر نتحدث على الارجنتين
انت كمختص كخبير في هذا المجال يعني ما
الذي نقص منتخب الارجنتين لكي يخسر هذه
الخساره الغير معتاده يعني على لعبه في
العاده
شنو طبعا المنتخب الارجنتين فريق المنتخب
لا يستاهل فيه منتخب معروف في القاره
العالم ولكن انا اعتقد المنتخب الارجنتين
كان يعني نقول فيه ان النتيجه كانت مضمونه
بالنسبه لمنتخب الارجنتين ولكن اعتقد
دائما المفاجات هي من تكون تفاجئ همم
المنتخب اللي هو مرشح المنتخب السعودي
تفاجئ المنتخب الارجنتيني وخاصه في الشوط
الثاني يعني كره القدم دائما بالعطاء
دائما بالقتاليه المنتخب السعودي اثبت امس
انه كره القدم كل شيء يحدث فيها امام
لاعبين لهم باع طويل في كره القدم الاسماء
رنانه في عالم كره القدم فهذه هي الاشياء
اللي حصلت امس بالنسبه للمنتخب
السعودي لا شك انه ما قبل كاس العالم كان
هناك متابعه من قبل الاجهزه الفنيه
بالنسبه للمنتخب الارجنتين لانه المنتخب
السعودي مباريات الوديه
شيء طبيعي انه يكون لاي منتخب متابعه ولكن
انا اعتقد انه كل التدوينات اللي دونت على
المنتخب السعودي امس امس اتلغت من المستوى
اللي قدم المنتخب السعودي والمستوى اللي
اذهل كل العرب واذهل كل العالم متابعين
صحيح انا مفاجاه ولكن مفاجاه كان في مستوى
انك تفوز على ميسي ورفاقه يعني
نركز على هذه النقطه
داخل الملعب
امس شفنا التمركز الجيد شوفنا الانتشار
جيدنا القوه الدفاع السعودي امس وهو
عمليات الاخفاء للمناطق الخلفيه والمسانده
من جميع من لعيبه الهجوم الى اللاعبين
الوسط اللي كانوا اول في خطبه سواهم
واعتقد حارس المرمى امس العويس في قمه
مستوى صحيح انه كان فيه بعد الهفوات الشوط
الاول في الدفاع ولكن الشوط الثاني بشكل
كبير المنتخب السعودي دائما المنتخب
السعودي التاريخ